mon périple olympique se poursuit vers
le parc naturel régional loire anjou
touraine
la petite commune de beaumont en véron a
tout d'une grande
grâce à la jeune gymnaste de 17 ans
carolin déduit qu'ils se préparent pour
les jo de tokyo
le club de gymnastique d'indre-et-loire
avoine beaumont gymnastique est un
vivier de talents depuis de nombreuses
années carolin déduit revient des
championnats d'europe où il s'est classé
à la 12e place du concours général
une performance évidemment encourageante
pour sa participation aux jeux
olympiques on va le savoir sans plus
attendre puisqu'elle s'entraîne à
l'intérieur de ce complexe sportif un
complexe dernier cri vous allez le voir
avec des installations qui datent de
2004 et voilages entre à l'intérieur
vous le voyez de cette salle
d'entraînement d'avoine beaumont
gymnastique le club de gym ici est
installé depuis 2004 évidemment vous le
voyez à la rigueur et le silence sont de
mise
et surtout il faut enlever ses
chaussures ici pour marcher sur les
praticables c'est ce que je veux faire
on laisse ça et je n'ai rejoindre
carolanne qui est sûr l'une des poutres
en plein entraînement
[Musique]
les bras alors caroline je viens de
rejoindre mais ce que tu peux me montrer
comment mon sur la poutre pour toi c'est
pas compliqué parce que tu as l'habitude
ah oui d'accord je suis pas certain
d'avoir équilibre en fait pour tenir
mais ça marche ne va pas faire
l'interview comme ça quand même
on peut descendre on peut s'asseoir au
moins sera plus pratique ça fait combien
taux qui s'entraînent ici ça fait mal
huitième année ici que je m'entraîne et
comment tu as découvert le club avec du
coup dans son club que mon entraîneur
retrouver j'avais du potentiel dont ben
m'a fait découvrir ce club et voilà j'y
suis depuis huit ans et donc là tu
prépares les jeux olympiques de tokyo
comment tu te sens en fait à ce que tu
envisages ça plutôt sereinement
bah en fait oui assez j'ai je me suis
toujours dit qu'il fallait pas que je me
fasse je me projette trop trop loin
voilà c'est prêt mais voilà je préfère
prendre le temps comme il vient et lads
par exemple de penser à mes
entraînements d'abord d'abord il ya eu
quatre ans après il va y avoir d'autres
sélections où je prends les choses comme
elles viennent et comme ça ça va mais
comment tu gères ton stress en fait
quand tu es sur les agrée par exemple
tout se joue sur la respiration pour moi
parce que je suis aussi stressé quand je
fais une édition l'année dernière
j'avais tendance un peu à perdre mes
moyens à me mettre à trembler et bon
c'est vrai que j'ai fait beaucoup
d'exercices au four à pour essayer d'y
remédier évidemment il faut encore
beaucoup travailler ici d'ailleurs tu
travailles le matin l'après midi
quasiment 7 jours sur 7
quasiment oui merci carolanne est ce que
pour terminer tu peux montrer une de ses
figures favorites sur cette poutre oui
vous avez bien sûr alors je vous promets
pas de refaire la même chose mais on va
voir si elle est assez fascinant
j'essaierai comme tu montreras les bases
[Musique]
debout oui qu'est-ce que je fais
d'autres après parce que là j'ai réussi
[Musique]
à lui c'est juste un pivot en fait oui
on va s'arrêter là je prends ça on a
assez pris ton temps aujourd'hui donc je
te laisse aller rejoindre ses camarades
pour la suite de ton entraînement qu'est
ce que tu vas faire à présent que l'âge
est allé aux barres asymétriques donc
sûrement faire quelques quelques baisses
pour préparer cet après-midi d'accord et
cette fois tu me proposes pas d'aller
avec toi tu sais que je vais rater tapas
à en dire plus a ra j'ai compris
[Musique]
faut habituellement que j'ai d'abord
pour être plus haut tu sais tu jettes
d'abord avec une action là le corps il
est trop bas t'as pas le temps
d'enchaîner le deuxième élément au
quotidien vous vous êtes présents alors
le matin l'après midi six jours sur sept
quasiment autant que les gymnastes
finalement ça vous demande beaucoup
d'énergie
ouais plus tout ce qui va autour parce
que nous on organise l'école on organise
le suivi médical en organise les stages
les compétitions donc ça va bien au delà
de l'entraînement c'est plus
psychologiquement que c'est éprouvant
parce qu'en fait comme tout le monde a
des attentes tout le monde souhaite un
bon la réussite la réussite une belle
compétition
je pense qu'à une charge émotionnelle
une charge psychologique très importante
chez l'athlète
donc moi je serais pour vous aussi oui
mais moi je suis assez peu sensibles à
ça je reste concentré sur l'objectif
et puis je n'oublie pas que la gym c'est
une partie de la vie moi je mets la vie
d'abord de l'athlète dans sa globalité
et la gym c'est un petit morceau
moi je leur dis tout le temps on fait un
petit parcours ensemble on fait un petit
bout de chemin pour rester avec nous ou
cinq en six ans huit ans pour caravanes
mais après elles vont faire autre chose
il faut qu'elle en garde le meilleur
souvenir possible alors tout en étant
exigeant tout en essayant de faire de
bons résultats
justement là elle est en train de vous
attendre donc on va vous laisser parce
que je suffisamment interrompu
l'entraînement et on sait qu'il est
important de ne pas se refroidir
je vous laisse avec carolanne merci
beaucoup
[Musique]